[Music]
where'd you go hey you are hi how's it
going doing pretty well I'm bored of the
beach one of the beach so check this out
this is a movie room with seats big TV
I'm pretty sure this room is bigger than
my entire apartment well that looks so
dramatic I have an alarm so you don't
push this button that says door alarm it
goes off to breathe
there he is there he is
you were you
Jen what you readin
it sounds like a really good
this wait a minute I definitely hear
it's this way what are we gonna get I
can hear it's so close I scream and fail
they're getting ready for a meal out on
my boat my mother is not too excited
about that because she's afraid that
we're all gonna die or that okay we
gotta get this thing out of here now
[Music]
okay okay Bri ng I'm gonna go over okay
here we go we have a go row row your
boat we're out here on the ocean
[Music]
[Applause]
why don't we just leave it up right
[Music]
that's a four and a half minutes we're
still crabs I went down today right
position rather dog missus she's fallen
my dad definitely just clowns
Wow look at this fancy little fishy crab
I'll go if you don't see the fight Jen
what do you want to see him do no no no
pair those hard work hey guys I'm
missing out here come for a ride things
never ride hey guys a so I'm all ready
to go out and my sisters are not ready
they told me to hurry up you Randy we're
going out and guess what they're not
ready so we're gonna go downstairs and
see if they're almost ready are you
ready yet I'll be ready brief no going
party pizza yeah alrighty a party it's
probably gonna be going to karaoke so
what happens
[Music]
[Applause]